So now we need to continue a message we left off in the middle of last week and that message
was January the 23rd, 1924.
This is Volume 16 and it's about the three fiats, do you remember?
Okay.
So in the paragraph we finished with the Lord was explaining to Louisa that she had to
be the one to bring the third fiat.
Now naturally enough that's extremely difficult for her because she's the first, I mean she's
never heard of anything like this before.
So almost confused, notice the almost by what Jesus was telling me, Louisa said, "My sweet
love, you know how miserable I am and in what state I find myself.
Therefore I feel it is impossible for me that with my acts I may reach the same way as that
of the creating fiat and the redeeming fiat."
Now Louisa knows the priests will say to her, "Listen, this is crazy.
You can't do what God does."
So Jesus has to explain it.
So Jesus said, "So our fiat does not contain all the power that it wants, so I want to
give you Matthew 17, 20, Matthew 17, 20 and Matthew 19, 26."
So if the fiat did in creation and in redemption, how can it not be able to do it in you?
In other words, is anything impossible with God?
Because it's the divine will that carries it out and if he's going to do something through
you, it requires your will.
And I will impress my fiat in yours, just as I impress my divine fiat in the will of my
humanity, so we will follow the same way.
My will can do anything, Luke 1, 37, nothing is impossible with God.
And my all-seeingness, which is Psalm 139, and with my all-seeingness, it will present
to you the acts of creation and redemption and you with ease, with your acts will braid
the third fiat on our fiat.
So if I ever put Philippians 4, 13 there, I can do all things in Christ who gives me
the strength.
Oh, he says, "Aren't you happy?" I don't think she knows whether she is or not.
And he said, "I, in seeing that my adored Jesus as he was speaking about his will, was
disappearing from me."
She was more worried about that, but she sees something new, remaining as though eclipsed
within an immense light.
This is going to become more and more the reality as we go on in the volumes.
Now the immense light of God, 1 Timothy 6, 16, God lives in unapproachable light.
And then, of course, 1 John 1, 5, God is light, okay?
And Psalm 104, verse 2, "Lord, you are wrapped in a robe of light."
I love that expression, it describes perfectly the transfiguration of Jesus.
So you remain as though eclipsed within an immense light just as when the sun makes the
stars disappear, eclipsing them within its light, said, "Jesus, my life, do not speak
to me about your will because then you will eclipse yourself within its light and I lose
you and remain alone without you."
Now, Louisa has the same problem as a small child.
When you turn out the lights, Mommy has disappeared, she has gone off the planet.
She may be standing outside the door hoping you would sleep, but the light is off and
therefore I don't see anything.
So Jesus is trying to explain to her that his humanity is eclipsed because the divine
light is much greater than his humanity.
And he says to her, "But you are eclipsed from me as well.
You are lost in that light as well.
You don't realize this."
And of course, if you look up in the day and you see only the sun, the stars are eclipsed
by the sun, but they are there.
And it's only when the sun withdraws its light that we can actually see the stars.
So this is what he's going to try and say to her.
So initially she says, "Don't talk about this because you'll disappear on me.
How can it be that your will makes me lose my life, my all?"
And he said, "My daughter, my humanity is smaller than my eternal will.
Because he had to pick up his humanity on the earth.
It has its boundaries.
It has its limits.
And therefore, as my endless will draws near you with its knowledge, my humanity is lost
within its light as though it eclipsed."
So I put Luke 9.29 there.
And I can't remember why.
So my humanity is lost within its light as though it eclipsed.
This is why you do not see me.
But I'm always in you.
Now you do not see me as one Peter, one eight.
The Peter is describing to the early church that you don't see him, but you love him and
you're still filled with all the joy and glory of your redemption.
And I remain always in you, that's your Luke 1721, the kingdom of God is within you.
And I enjoy, as I see the little newborn of my will, eclipsed within the same light as
my humanity.
So why is she eclipsed as well?
It's because the two of them are one.
The two wills are one.
So we are together.
And because our sight is dazzled.
That means his humanity and her humanity.
By the blazing light of the Supreme Volition, we cannot see each other.
So Louisa has to come to accept something that we have all been taught about the relationship
with God.
Is the front door closed?
And that is that your inner perception is the important one.
Not what your physical eyes see.
Okay.
So February the 2nd, 1924.
I love this one.
It's all about abandonment.
And I think all of us are ready for this one.
Abandonment forms the wings in order to fly.
So this airplane to get off the ground has to have wings.
And I think the name of the two wings are surrender and trust.
Surrender and trust to get us off the ground.
Okay.
And of course, loss of abandonment and trust means an air disaster in the divine will because
you crash land, you come right back.
Okay.
So, before I even read this, I want to give you something I gave you many times before.
And that is the surrendered soul has found paradise on earth.
That's the words of St. Madeline de Clerk.
I don't expect that you know her.
I think she was the foundress of the sisters of the Sacred Heart.
Louisa said, I felt very oppressed because of the privation of my sweet Jesus and because
of other reasons which is not necessary to put on paper.
And my beloved Jesus moving in my interior, that's your Luke 1721, pressing me to himself
to give me strength, for I felt I was succumbing, told me, my daughter, my will is the life
and the motion of everything.
That's a very important statement, everything, the whole universe and anything that lives
on the earth.
But do you know who follows its motion and takes flight in my eternal volition in such
a way as to go around as it does in the sphere of eternity, be wherever it is and do whatever
it does.
Now, look at this because you can't talk about the soul in the divine will.
Who's the one who goes around the sphere of eternity and is wherever the divine will
is and does whatever it does.
It is the soul who is completely abandoned, now I ring the word completely, because we're
all partly, completely abandoned to the divine will.
So completely abandoned means Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You love the Lord with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind and all your being
and you trust Him.
You're not just trusting your own head.
So abandonment, my book says is the wings, it's not English, abandonment forms the wings
in order to fly together with my will.
As abandonment ceases, she loses the flight and the wings are destroyed.
So I call that the air crash.
Notice that the book is talking to you about air flight.
So everyone feels the motion, the life of my will, because there is no motion which does
not come from me.
And they, that is those without abandonment, remain at the point in which they were.
There's no take off.
Only one who has the wings of abandonment in me and follows the same course as my will,
covers over everything, both in heaven and on earth and enters into the sphere of eternity
and goes round in the midst of the three divine persons, penetrates into their most intimate
hiding places and is aware of their secrets and of their beatitudes.
That's quite a statement.
So I just had to give it here all in one, we'll go back.
So only one who has the wings of abandonment in me, now you know I'm going to be talking
to you about flight, don't you, and an aircraft and all the rest, it's all here.
So only one who has the wings of abandonment in me and follows the same course as my will.
In other words, we don't have an agenda of our own.
Only that person hovers over everything and therefore can influence everything, both
in heaven and on earth.
That's the first thing, that person hovers over everything.
Now when you go to the Bible, you find at the dawn of creation that the spirit of God
hoovered over the chaos and then the word of God came forth to bring it all into being
or to bring order out of chaos, that's actually what he did.
And that's what he's trying to do in the divine will as well.
When you come to the dawn of redemption, you have the Holy Spirit hovering over our blessed
mother, the mother of the Redeemer.
And when you come to the Redeemer himself, you have the Holy Spirit hovering over Jesus
that is baptism.
Now the hovering of the spirit means that God is going to do something tremendous.
Okay, so if the soul in the divine will hovers over everything, it means that God is going
to do incredible work through that soul, both in heaven and on earth.
So that person also enters into the sphere of eternity, which he will describe in the
next paragraph.
That soul goes round in the midst of the three divine persons in the midst of, that you're
talking about, therefore, the very essence of God, the very center of the universe, the
very, I don't know how to put it, the first beginning, it's right in the heart of everything.
Not only do you go around in the midst of the three divine persons, they penetrate into
their most intimate hiding places, I'll give you a comment on this in a second.
And because of that, they are aware of their secrets and of their beatitudes.
Now right from the very beginning of these volumes, you saw that the Lord began to reveal
his secrets, what he was doing on the earth and why and all the rest are gradually revealed
to Louisa.
And even though she has to suffer for her brothers and sisters on the earth, she still
has this extraordinary joy of being in this relationship.
So you have the secrets and the beatitudes.
Now there's a big thing in the Bible about the council of God, being in the council of
God.
I want to give you the inner court of the Lord from Ezekiel 8 verse 3 and 16, the inner
court.
As you know, the temple in Jerusalem had an outer court where eventually at the time of
Christ even the Gentiles could go into it.
And then you had an inner court for the women of Israel and then the men and the priests
and then the Holy of Holies.
So that's Ezekiel 8 verse 3 and verse 16.
But you have another concept as well, and that is someone taken into the inner council
of God.
And that's where the saints are taken.
And that's the position that Louisa is in, that the Lord actually tells her what's going
on and explains his actions towards the human race and everything.
So for that I want to give you Jeremiah 2318, where Jeremiah challenged the false prophets,
of you being in the council of God.
And also Sam 82 verse 1.
Now that's a big subject, I'm just giving you just a few references to it.
So Jesus is saying that someone who lives in the divine will, so this is your total
abandonment stage, is brought right into the very heart of the Trinity, into the council
of God, into the inner court.
So of course you know the secrets.
It happens, it happens as too, is an expression that you use quite frequently.
We would say it's the same as.
So it's the same as an engine, which has the primary wheel in the center and many other
small wheels around it, which are fixed.
Now to me that's the Swiss watch.
So you have your big wheel and the tiny little wheels all around it.
So you move the big wheel and all the little ones move as well.
As the primary wheel moves, all receive motion.
But they never arrive at touching the primary wheel because they're fixed, is that okay?
Nor do they know anything of what the primary wheel does or of the goods that it contains.
But there's another small wheel.
Now the small wheel is the sole in the divine will and it's not fixed.
And by means of a mechanism, if you go down one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
lines, in my book, the mechanism is complete abandonment of the divine will.
Do you see that?
It's towards the end of that paragraph.
So he says, by means of a certain mechanism, which is abandonment of the divine will, this
sole goes round continuously across all the small wheels so that the influence is on the
whole machine.
Now he's talking about the machine of the universe.
And then find itself in each motion of the primary wheel.
Now this is another image for the inner courts of the Lord to begin its round again.
And now this little itinerant wheel, I love being called an itinerant one, knows what
is there in the primary wheel and takes part in the goods that it contains.
Now the primary wheel is my will.
And the small wheels which are fixed are the soles that are abandoned to themselves.
Oh, oh, I think you need to call it at a different color to the other color you're using.
The soles that are abandoned to themselves, they're not gone anywhere, which renders them
immobilized in good.
The little itinerant wheel is the sole who lives in my will and the mechanism is the complete
abandonment to me.
In other words, you get enormous freedom in the kingdom if you just simply abandon yourself
to the Lord.
So each lack of abandonment in me is a round that you lose in the sphere of eternity.
Oh, he said, if you only knew what it was to lose an eternal round.
We've no concept, of course, of an eternal round.
Okay, so the next paragraph is all about the wheel of eternity.
And when I come to a point like this in Louisa, I can't draw for nuts, I start drawing.
It actually makes huge sense if you start drawing it, that the divine will is a sphere.
And out of that comes this continuous overflow of all these things.
He sends out new love, new beauty, new grace, new life, new everything.
And it's continuous.
Okay.
We have to participate in it.
It calls this the sphere of eternity.
And it has no beginning or no end.
And that's why the church has always used a circle for God.
It's no beginning or no end.
But the Irish monks decide that they'd improve on the circle.
Can you improve on the circle?
Yes, you can give it swing one, swing two and swing three for the three persons in the
Trinity.
But it's all one line.
And the beauty of the book of Kells is to see what they did.
They did the Trinity this way, the Father, the Son and the Holy Spirit, all one line.
And so it is still the sphere of eternity would put into your shamrock.
It's a fantastic thing, you know.
So here's the wheel of eternity.
On hearing this, Louisa said, "But to me, my love, what does eternity mean?
What is this eternal round?"
And Jesus added, "My daughter, eternity is an immense circle."
Now, I'm not going to go down this route just right now, but in these writings you
will find, as you do in the Bible, that there are certain geometrical shapes that are considered
perfect and reflect what God is and what God is doing.
One of them is the circle, one of them is the cube.
A cube is a perfect thing.
Another one is aniqui-ic.
Yeah, you see.
I should never get around it.
But what you call it, the angles are the same.
Yeah.
Those three represent God absolutely perfectly.
Yes.
And so the scientists are right when they tell you mathematics gives you the whole story.
The scientists are actually right.
I was never good at math, but never mind.
So eternity is an immense circle, such that one cannot know either where it begins or
where it ends.
So the circle is the eternity, okay?
In this circle there is God, without beginning and without end.
And there He possesses infinite happiness, infinite beatitude, infinite joys, infinite
riches, infinite beauties, and all the rest of His attributes, okay?
At each divine motion which never ceases, He issues new happiness, new beauty, new beatitudes,
new joy, new everything, okay?
Now I've written Sam one, two, one, verse four beside that, and He does it from the circle
of eternity, that is where He is Himself.
But each new act is an act that is never interrupted.
You see, this is leading to Him saying to Louisa and to us that our surrender and our
acts must never be interrupted.
Have you worked out how that can happen?
But how often do you fuse?
How do you do it all the time?
Yeah, but I'm not actually saying that.
See, if an act is to be uninterrupted and it starts at six o'clock in the morning, it
goes on forever.
There is no stop.
The only way I know how to handle it may not be the right thing, but the only way I know
how to handle it is to say to the Lord, I am placing the intention that from this moment
to the moment of my death, including my last breath, this is what I'm doing.
That's the way I cover it, to be an uninterrupted act, you know what I mean?
But I tell myself two or three times a day to make sure I remember, He's not going to
have a problem remembering, it's us that has the problem remembering, but it's placing
the intention that this is what I want to do.
And He tells us in the early volumes that placing the intention is extremely important,
doesn't He?
That's the only way I know how to solve it.
If you find a better way, tell me, I'm open.
So it's an action that doesn't cease, okay.
And it's the unceasing part of the action that we have to get around.
It's never interrupted.
So one is different from the other, distinct among ourselves.
Our contentments are always new.
Our beatitudes are such and so many that while we are enjoying one, another one surprises
us.
Now in this continuous act, there's got to be different things because He's saying that
everything is different.
You know, there's beauty and happiness and peace and joy and all the rest of us love
and all the rest of us.
So how do you cover that?
All I can do is tell you what I do.
I'm not saying it's right, it's just my attempt to respond to this.
That's all it is.
And that is I say to the Lord, at every nanosecond, you know what a nanosecond is?
One millionth of a second.
Every nanosecond of my whole life from this moment to the last breath that I take, in
your divine will, I want to adore, praise, bless, honor, worship, praise, and love you.
You see, the different acts, you can't physically do it at every moment, but you can place the
intention that this is what you want to do and He says, "If you desire it, I'll do it."
Is that okay?
All I'm trying to do is say how I attempt to respond to this.
I'm not saying it's right, it's just the way I try to respond to it.
So He says that these acts that come out of this continuous act are all different.
Our contentments are always new.
Everything in God is new.
He never patches.
Do you remember, He said that Christianity was not a patch on Judaism, okay?
Our beatitudes are such and so many that while we are enjoying one another surprises us,
and it's always so, and they never end their eternal, immense just as we are.
And what is eternal has the power of making ever new things arise?
So I have a whole spate of references for you that the Lord always wants to do a new
thing.
Is that okay?
I'm not going to give you this in any proper order or anything, Ezekiel 18, 31.
This is all about God doing a new thing.
Lamentations 3, 23.
Isaiah 42, 9, Isaiah 43, 19, Isaiah 62, 2, Isaiah 65, 17, Revelation 21, 1 and 5.
There are more, but the Lord always wants to do a new thing, and it's important for
us to remember that in our own life experience as well, that the Lord always wants to do something
new.
You just want to patch up your past, you're going to hear that on Saturday.
And what He says is, "What is old, things that are repeated, they don't exist in what
is eternal."
How is that?
What is old, things that are repeated, they don't exist in eternity, everything's new.
That's why you won't be bored in heaven, everything's new all the time.
But do you know who it is that in heaven shares more in this newness and is never exhausted?
It is one who has practiced more good on the earth.
This good will be like a seed which will bring the soul the knowledge of our Beatitudes,
joys, beauty, love, goodness and all the other attributes of God.
And depending on the good which the soul has practiced on the earth, which is in some harmony
with our varied Beatitudes, she will come closer to us and will find herself in large
gulps, will fill herself in large gulps with that Beatitude whose seed she contains.
Now several times in these writings, when Jesus was explaining love, he brought Aliwish's
Gonzaga out of heaven to meet Louisa and told her that he took his Ph.D. in love.
They're my words.
Okay.
So he illustrated for her what he meant when he was describing love.
So whatever area that we have majored in, if I can put it that way, that is going to
be the area that will open most for us in heaven, other areas will open up as well.
It's interesting, isn't it?
So she will come closer to us and she will fill herself in large gulps with that Beatitude
whose seed she contains to the point of overflowing outside.
Once you're John 7, 37 to 39, from your own heart will flow fountains of living water.
Okay.
She will share in everything that the circle of eternity contains, look at the generosity
of God.
And she will be filled with it in place of the seeds acquired on earth.
So I just want you to do CF, that means compare, look at this other text, it's not directly
on it.
So compare one Corinthians three versus 11 to 15, where Paul is speaking on a much lower
level to people at a much earlier stage in their relationship with God.
And he's saying to them that your Beatitude in heaven will be parallel to the good you've
done on earth.
So he's saying it at another level.
So it will happen as to one who has learned music.
So we now get the example, the illustration, okay.
And his examples are very interesting.
Like I would never have taken music as the example to illustrate this.
So watch this.
Take music or a job or a science area.
He said, when music is played many listen and enjoy, but who understands it?
Who feels all those notes of joy or sorrow penetrates into his intelligence and descend
into his heart?
Who feels as though being filled and seeing in act the scenes that the music actually expresses?
It's one who has studied, and one who's worked hard on it, that's very interesting because
it's telling us the more we study, the more we open ourselves up to the deepest understandings
and therefore the deepest experience.
The others enjoy the music, but they don't understand.
I agree with that completely.
Their enjoyment is in what sounds to their ears, but their whole interior remains empty.
That's very interesting, isn't it?
So the music isn't actually giving them any ecstasy.
It's the same for one who has learned sciences, who enjoys one more, one who has studied and
worn out his intelligence over books, over many scientific things, are the one who's
only looked at them.
Indeed, it's the one who has studied, can earn fair profits, can occupy distinct positions
while the other one can only enjoy with his sight if he sees things related to the sciences.
The same with all other things.
If this happens on Earth, he said, much more so does it happen in heaven, where just as
ways with the scales of love, every little good act done by the creature, that really
needs to be underlined.
And on that good act places an unending happiness, joy and beauty.
So first of all, I want to give you Matthew 25, 34.
That's the final judgment seen in Matthew's Gospel.
Enter into the joy of your Lord because you did these acts.
Luke 12, 7.
And Luke 21, 18.
Because you have Jesus' parables as well in which the man with ten talents ends up with
the one talent of the man who refused to use them.
Now, what will be for the soul who has lived in my will in which all her acts remain in
an eternal and divine seed?
The circle of eternity will pour itself upon her to such an extent that the whole celestial
Jerusalem will remain stupefied and will make new feasts and will enjoy new glory.
Now notice that the Jerusalem that is to come, which St John speaks about in the book of
Revelation at the moment only exists in heaven among the blessed.
But when the divine will is actually running on the earth as it is in heaven, the Jerusalem
will come down to the earth and that will be God's triumph.
So February 5, 1924, this is about the divine will again.
Louisa said, "I feel embittered because of the privation of my highest and only good.
Even more, I felt that everything was over for me and that the one who is my life was
to come no more and that all the past had been a game of fantasy."
Now she gets that problem frequently.
"Oh, had it been in my power, I would have burnt up all the writings so that no trace
might be left about me.
My nature also felt the painful effects of this."
Okay, that is the soul communicates its pain to the body.
And this is something we're going to have to look into.
The world is going to have to change its approach to medicine because a lot of the time it is
soul pain that the person has.
I remember meeting a doctor at once who was absolutely brilliant, had incredible success
with these patients.
And it's because he would sit the person down and the person would give the symptoms
and all the rest of it.
And the doctor would look at the person and thinking of one particular case was a case
of a woman who gave him whatever symptoms she had.
And the doctor looked at her and he said, "What's your relationship with your mother
like?"
And she said, "What's that got to do with my symptoms?"
He said, "It's everything to do with them.
You're expressing it in your body."
He said, "Go home.
Be reconciled with your mother.
Go out and celebrate and come back.
And if you still have the symptoms, he said, "I'll give you something for them."
The woman was healed when she reconciled with her mother.
You see, the soul pain expresses itself in the body.
And when we deal with it, then the soul is released and the body, too, is released.
And I think, myself, that that's part of coming back into the divine order.
And that's why on our journey into the fullness of divine will, where the Lord has to do a
lot of work on us to make sure that the trouble that our body has experienced as a result
of our journey, that they've all got to be dealt with and the body just gradually come
back into order.
Does that make sense?
To me, the body will come back into order.
The mind will come back into order.
The emotions will come back into order.
Everything will come back into order.
It'll be a wonderful thing.
So my nature also felt the painful effects of this.
So the body is expressing the pain of the soul.
In medical terms, they call that psychosomatic.
In Ireland, they made dreadful mistakes about this in the past.
It sits on your head.
They were partly right, and a half truth is very dangerous.
My nature, too, felt the painful effects of this, but it is useless to say on paper what
I went through, because the paper, too, cruel, has not a word of comfort for me, and does
not give me the one whom I so much long for.
On the contrary, by saying it, it makes my pains more bitter, therefore I move on.
So while I was in such a hard state, my beloved Jesus made himself a scene.
This is fascinating.
With a stick of fire, not a stick of wood in his hand, telling me, "My daughter, where
do you want me to be, too, with this stick?"
So I want to strike the world, and therefore I've come to you to see how many blows you
want to receive yourself so as to give rest to them.
How much do you love your neighbor?
You see, if we really let go the self, I'm not in it for me.
If we really let the human will surrender to the divine will, then it's what God wants
is the only thing that we want, okay?
And he wants that all people will be saved and come to the knowledge of the truth.
He wants the whole out of them.
It doesn't matter whether they're in good religions or bad religions.
What color they are, what culture, what age, or anything else, he wants everyone saved
and come to the knowledge of the truth.
So you'll find that in Paul's first letter to Timothy, and you'll find it in the Acts
of the Apostles.
You won't have the verses.
So tell me where you want me to beat you.
And Louisa, who is so embittered at the time, she said, "Beat me wherever you want to beat
me.
I don't want to know anything.
I only, I want nothing but your will."
Just watch her incredible freedom here, okay?
And he again, he said, "I want to know from you where you want me to beat you."
In other words, I want to know your will on the subject.
And Louisa said, "No, no, no.
I'll never do that.
I want there where you want."
And Jesus turned to ask me again, seeing that I kept answering, "I want nothing but
your will."
So he repeated.
So you don't even want to say where you want me to beat you.
In other words, Louisa is trying to not let her will have any space at all.
And this is the test that's given to her, okay?
And because that's what you're told about both Jesus in his humanity and blessed mother,
that they didn't give any space to their own will.
And so here's Jesus testing her and she says, "No, I only want your will.
I only want, I don't care what you do.
I only want your will."
That's incredible freedom, isn't it?
So, and the other thing you look at is she's already in incredible interior pain and she
still says yes to suffering for others.
So you're dealing with absolute heroism here.
Then without saying anything else, he beat me.
These blows were painful, but since they were coming from the hands of Jesus, I have to
change the English here a bit.
They infused light into me and also strength and trust.
So because they were coming from Jesus, he gave me light, strength and trust as well.
So after he struck me in such a way that I felt all beaten up, I cloned to his neck
and drawing near his mouth, I tried to suckle.
And usually when she does that, she's looking for Tisha and his bitterness.
But as I did so, a most sweet liquid came into my mouth, which cheered me all up, notice
the balance.
It's not suffering for suffering's sake.
It's that it's a redemptive suffering that's asked.
But this was not my will, she said.
Her will was that she was willing to take the bitterness.
Rather, I wanted his bitterness, for he had so many in his holy heart, and then I said
to him, "My love, what a hard lot is mine, your privation kills me.
The fear that I might go out of your will crushes me.
Tell me, where have I offended you?
Why do you leave me?"
And even though you are with me now, it seems to me that you haven't come to stay like.
I love that.
You see, just how much she loves him, it's really fantastic.
It seems to me that you have come to stay with me like, not come to stay with me like
before, to be together, but you've come in passing.
How can I be without you my life?
You yourself tell me if I can."
And while I was saying this, I burst into tears.
Now, she's not crying because she's all beaten up.
She's not crying because of the terrible bitterness that she's experiencing.
She's crying only because she doesn't want him to shift one inch from where he is.
It's fascinating because this love can't be without the beloved.
So Jesus pressing me to Himself told me, "Poor daughter of mine, poor daughter of
mine, courage, your Jesus does not leave you.
That's Joshua 1.5, I'll never leave you or desert you."
Or should you fear that you might go out of my will because your will is chained to the
immutability of mine.
So you see how far she has gone in the divine will.
You know, in a, I don't know if they use this language anymore, I might be indicating my
age here, but there's a point of no return on a flight that if they get to a certain
point, there's no point in going back.
Going forward is actually better.
She's gone beyond the point of no return.
She's actually gone into that sphere of eternity.
So she's living the life of the blessed on earth.
It's absolutely incredible.
So she participates in the immutability.
She's not going to change.
Agnes, fantastic.
So here I have given a Deuteronomy 31.6, Hebrews 13.5, and John 14.18, and all of them
the Lord is saying, "If you are my servant, if you are doing my will, if you are doing
what I want, I am with you."
So he said, "At most it might be thoughts or impressions that you will feel, but not
true acts."
Now we're moving on into the higher planes here of the divine will, and your nature might
react to something, but your will hasn't shifted.
So your body and your emotions are registering something you have not put your will into
it.
It's just thoughts or impressions, and you just push them aside, you don't even give
them any thought.
It's fantastic, isn't it?
It's an unbelievable thing.
He has told us right from the very beginning that the problem is only in the will and in
early stages when she wanted to be resentful about somebody, say, "Don't put your will
into it."
So now he's saying to her, "No, there's just thoughts and impressions that pass through
your head."
Isn't it wonderful?
There's a wonderful freedom here.
He said, "They're not true acts.
The act involves the will."
Okay.
"In fact, since the immutability of my will is in you, when yours might be about to go
out of mine, you will feel the firmness and the strength of my immutability and you'll
remain chained more to it."
Now, the advantage of being at this point is the weakness of human nature will always
be there, okay?
The reaction of our poor humanity will always be the same.
But he says, at this particular point, when this weakness touches you because you are
chained to the divine will, you have the strength of the divine will coming in to bring you
over that hurdle.
I think it's fantastic.
He says, "My immutability helps you to deal with it and you become even more strained."
Now, that strength is what we call fortitude, and I always say that fortitude is the steel
girders for your soul, keeps you steady when the storms come.
"And besides," he said, "have you forgotten that I am not only in your heart, but I'm
in the whole world, watch this now, and from within you I direct the destiny of all creatures."
So where is the throne of God on earth?
It's in the heart of Louisa.
So it would be any harm to put throne there beside it.
From you I direct the destiny of all creatures.
What you feel is nothing other than the way that the world is with me.
So it's at this high point that you can say that the sadness I am feeling right now is
not actually mine.
It's the sadness that the world is giving to Jesus.
So I click into Jesus' sadness in Gethsemane and in his will offered to try and help others.
And at a very early stage I don't think you could make that presumption.
I think at an early stage I'd know, who's me, I don't know about you.
So we have to be terribly honest about this.
It's only at this, she's beyond the point of no return.
At this point she can be absolutely sure that whatever she's experiencing, it's actually
his and he's giving it to her to save souls.
But when we hop on to what we have we can pick up the pieces and join it to Jesus and
save souls as well.
But I do think we have to be honest.
What you feel is nothing other than the way the world is with me.
Now my reaction to this is first of all he reigns in us and everything is through him
and with him and in him.
And then he reigns through us and everything is through us and with us and in us.
Oh you got that one?
When you think about it it's unbelievable.
Everything initially is through him, with him and in him until he can make his throne
in us and then everything is through us, with us and in us.
It sounds wrong doesn't it?
What you feel is nothing other than the way the world is with me and the pains they give
me is what you're experiencing.
Since I am in you they are reflected upon you because in the divine will you meet all
souls, don't you?
Therefore you meet their problems.
Am I daughter?
How much does the world give us?
Now you see everything has changed.
He hasn't said this before.
It's the us.
It's no longer you and me.
It's us.
How much does the world give us to suffer?
And really mark the us there, it's a big change.
But come courage.
When I see that you can take no more, I leave everything.
Even if there's a world war on, he will leave everything.
What does he do?
Leaves the 99 and goes after the one sheep.
That's the way he operates.
When I see that you can take no more, I leave everything and I come to be with my daughter
to cheer you and to cheer myself from the pains that they give me.
Having said this, he disappeared.
I think it's absolutely incredible to think that he leaves all the other stuff that he's
doing for all other creatures and comes and spends time with this little one.
So to me, that's the shepherd and the sheep and all the references you have to shepherd
and sheep.
So Louisa said I was left saddened, yes, but with such melancholy.
Now, melancholy is an old word, literally means sadness and I wonder if it means depression.
Just my question mark that I felt myself dying, she said.
I felt as though soaked in a bath of bitterness and affliction.
That's why I would put the word depression on it.
So much so that I did not feel the strength to say to Jesus come.
Then while I was doing my usual prayers, the incredible thing is she goes on with her flights
in the divine will anyway, regardless of how she is, it's fantastic.
My beloved Jesus came back telling me, my daughter tell me, "Why are you so sad?"
Okay.
I looked this off and then I got distracted, didn't I?
Two Corinthians nine, I forgot to write it down, didn't I?
Two Corinthians nine, well, I've forgotten the verse, the phone went, "It says God loves
a cheerful giver."
You'll find it in two Corinthians nine, God loves a cheerful giver.
Why are you so sad?
You see, there's no sadness in heaven, and there's actually no sadness in the divine
will either.
See, I come from the midst of creatures with tears in my eyes, my heart is pierced, betrayed
by many, and so I say to myself, "Let me go to my daughter, my little newborn of my will,
that she may dry my tears," and here she is all sad.
With her acts that she has done in my will, she will give me the love and everything that
the others don't give me.
I will rest in her.
Do you see what he wants?
And I will cheer her with my presence, and you instead let yourself be found so sad that
I have to put my pains aside in order to relieve yours.
It should be the other way around.
Don't you know, that is two Corinthians nine, seven.
I did write it down, I just didn't see that I had written it.
Don't you know that cheerfulness for the soul is like fragrance for flowers.
It's not a beautiful image.
It's like condiment on foods, it makes a huge difference, and it's like skin tone for people
over a very, very sensitive about skin tone.
One of the things I used to joke with the girls in Africa about, I said, "You're trying
to make yourselves pale, an hour later trying to make them says dark, will you come to some
conclusion at some point, we're terribly sensitive about skin."
They wanted to lighten the skin and we wanted to darken the skin.
And I said, "Your problem is you get too much sun and we don't get enough."
It's like skin tone for people.
It's like maturation for fruits.
There's a particular point at which the fruit is fantastic.
Go beyond it, it's not so fantastic.
But look at the images he gives.
The images are so simple, they're so everyday, and that's what we want people to sort of
get used to.
It's like the sun for plants, okay?
So I want to give you a few two references from Proverbs, Proverbs 15, 13.
And Proverbs 17, 22.
So Jesus said, "With this melancholy you have not let me find a fragrance that may cheer
me or a tasty food or a mature fruit.
Rather, you're all fated."
Oh dear.
That's just having a bad day.
I hate the Lord to tell me I was all fated.
That might be true, but I wouldn't like him to tell me.
You're all fated.
It's supposed to move me to pity.
Poor dog.
He said, "Courage, cling to me and do not fear."
I cloned to him, Louisa said, "I would have wanted to burst into tears.
I felt my voice being suffocated, overcoming herself, but she's getting help, isn't she?
From the immutability.
But I plucked up strength, I repressed my tears, and I said to him, "Jesus, my love,
my pains are nothing compared to yours.
So let us think about your pains if you don't want to add more bitterness to mine.
So let me dry your tears and let me share in the pains of your heart.
So he shared his pains with me, and while letting me see the grave evils in the world
and those which were to come, that's your Amos 3.7, he shows the prophets ahead of time."
Now, the evils in the world and those that are to come, the first world war is over.
He starts showing her the second world war.
So just put World War II there.
He showed her the first world war for a number of years before it happened, and he showed
her the second world war for a number of years before it happened as well.
Okay.
So February the 8th, 1924, we're going to be talking about little souls.
This is very important.
I was fusing all of myself, see the all of myself in the holy divine will, and in doing
this as the littlest of all, that there's your nothingness, but there's your ant as distinct
from the elephant.
Do you remember I told some of you?
Okay.
I placed myself ahead of all generations, even before Adam and Eve were created, so that
before they would sin, I may prepare ahead of them an act of reparation to the divine
majesty, I just love that she makes an act of reparation before Adam and Eve sins.
I think that's brilliant.
So that I may prepare ahead of time an act of reparation to the divine majesty.
You see, this is a ministry to the glory of God, and so it's the same as the angels.
Their ministry is to the glory of God.
So I made an act of reparation to the divine majesty because in the divine will, there's
neither past nor future, everything is present.
That means God is a single point or what the astral physicists are now calling a singularity.
Okay, a singularity is so small that there can't be past or future in it.
It's less than the dot that your pen will make on the page.
Everything is present and also so that being little, I may approach the divine majesty
in order to plead with him and to do my little acts in his will so as to cover, now notice
not change their origins, to cover them, to cover all the acts of creatures with his
divine will because he'll tell us elsewhere that if an act has its origin in the human,
it will remain that way.
If it has its origin in the divine, it will remain that way, but he allows us to cover
other people's acts so they become more pleasing in his sight.
To cover all the acts of creatures with his divine will and therefore be able to bind
the human will which had split off with the divine and make them one.
So that's what Jesus was doing in his lifetime as well.
Now, while I was about to do this, my annihilation, my misery, and my extreme littleness were
such that I said to myself, instead of placing myself ahead of everybody in the most holy
will, I should rather place myself behind everybody.
Matthew 2312 and Luke 1411, that's taking the last place instead of the first place.
I should rather put myself behind everyone, even behind the last man who is to come.
So here's the acknowledgement of the nothingness.
Since I am the most abject and the most miserable of all, it is the last place that befits me.
So that's Matthew 2016, where Jesus said that he had taken the last place on earth.
The son of man came not to serve, not to be served, but to serve and to give his life
as a ransom for many.
Now, while I was doing this, my beloved Jesus came out from within my interior, Luke 1721.
Taking my hand, he told me, my daughter, my little daughter, in my will, the little ones
must be ahead of all, Matthew 1930.
Even more, there must be inside my womb, which again I put Matthew 2016.
One who must plead, repair, and unify our will, not only with our own, but with those
of all, must be near us, and must be so united with us as to receive all the reflections
of the divinity.
And I give you two Corinthians 3, 18.
That's receiving all the reflections of the divinity in order to copy them within herself.
She must have a thought which may be the thought of all, a word, a work, a step, a love which
may be for all, of all, and for all.
And since our will envelopes everyone, may that thought of yours, which our will, in our
will becomes the thought of all, that act, that love shine in each thought, word, and
act of all generations.
And in the power of our will, may they become antidotes, defenders, lovers, and operators,
but we don't change the origin of the act.
And that's a very important point to make.
So we'll just finish this one, and then we'll leave it for tonight.
If you knew Jesus said, "With what love, our celestial father awaits you, and the joy
the contentment he feels in seeing you so little."
If you understood the joy he has when you bring the whole of creation onto his lap to
give him the return of all, he feels the glory.
I'm going to give you John 10, 17.
He feels the glory, the joys, the amusement, and the purpose of creation coming back to
him.
This is why it's necessary that you come before all.
And after you've come forward, you will make a turn in our will, and will go behind everyone.
It's very interesting.
First of all, she had to go ahead of everyone, and now she goes behind them.
So she's the shield.
And you will place them as though on our lap, and will bring them all into our womb.
Now, beside that I've put John 13, 14 to 16, and underneath that Philippians 2, 6 to 11.
And we, he said, "In seeing them, covered with your acts done in our will, will welcome
them with more love, and will feel more disposed to bind our will with those of creatures,
so that it may return to its full dominion."
Now, my sense of that, I'm not saying it's right.
My sense of that is that what Louisa's asked to do is cover all the other acts.
That's like saying you put a very acceptable garment on top, and out of sheer love the
Lord looks at the garment and not underneath it.
He accepts what you've done.
You've put this garment of grace over their acts, which you can't change the original
act.
Is that okay?
I think it's beautiful.
And I think Lloyd has an image that might help us of the grace of the Lord being a garment
over us.
In your bag?
Yeah.
It just might help us.
It's wonderful, this is everything, everything comes in hand.
Look at it.
One of Elizabeth Wang's ones.
And there's Jesus having covered us with all of his grace and his glory.
Isn't it wonderful?
And if I'm in there, then I'm acceptable to the Father.
Aren't I?
Yeah.
I think that's what Louisa is actually talking about there.
I'm not just too late in darkness.
Yes, it's magnificent.
But you've got all the variations of color of graces and virtues and everything there
as well.
It's just wonderful.
And I think those pictures are very expressive because they're done on a mystical level.
They're not just done on an ordinary human level.
So here we are, and there's the blessed Trinity in seeing them, the people covered with your
acts done in the divine will welcome them with more love and will feel more disposed
to bind our will to those of creatures so that it may return to its full dominion.
Therefore courage, the little ones get lost in the crowd, and this is why it is necessary
that you come forward.
You'll be seen if you don't in order to fulfill the mission of your office in our will.
In our will, the little ones have no thoughts for themselves.
The little ones Matthew 18 verses 1 to 3.
The little ones get all the praise from Jesus.
They have no thoughts for themselves, nor their own things, but everything is in common
with the celestial father.
Therefore just as everyone enjoys the sun, as they are all inundated with its light, because
it was created by God for the good of all, in the same way all enjoy the use of the acts
done by the little daughter of the divine will.
Now there you're being told the whole human race benefits from your.
Isn't that wonderful?
So think of us being allowed to put a garment that is acceptable onto the human race before
the father.
I think that's a fantastic thing to make it much more acceptable, and for him to say
yes, I'll bring my will upon the earth.
In the same way all enjoy the use of the acts done by our little daughter in our will, which
more than the sun dart over all, so that the sun of the eternal volition may rise again
with that purpose for which all generations were created.
And I put a VIP on the next bit, therefore do not get lost in the crowd of your miseries.
Do not get lost in the crowd of your objection.
Do not get lost in the crowd of your self-reflections.
But think only about the offers of the little one of our will and the attentive to your mission.
It's a brilliant way to finish it.
It's not fantastic because we have such a tendency to fall back into that position.
Okay, we'll leave it there for now.